live by night is directed by Ben Affleck
starring Ben Affleck and is the story of
a gangster in the Prohibition era who's
going up the ranks so to speak he starts
kind of small he's doing things he
shouldn't he's robbing banks he's
sleeping with gangsters girlfriends and
eventually he gets to that point where
he's actually making some calls and
making some decisions and it's about how
he weaves in and out of this gangster
era of this time period now I've been a
big fan of Ben Affleck's directorial
efforts I love Gone Baby Gone I love the
town I loved Argo he has really proven
himself as a director and I would say
that's his best strength and in this
film he proves that once again because
this is a very good-looking movie with
terrific action set-pieces and some good
drama but it's unfortunately definitely
his worst film as a director in my
opinion because the film after its first
act begins to meander quite a bit and
can't really find its footing I would
say the first 30 minutes of this movie
were excellent I was on board there is
an incredibly awesome white knuckled
bank robbery chase scene there's a very
intriguing romance that's set up between
Ben Affleck and Sienna Miller and
without spoiling anything there's a
montage of about one minute that
involves some prison time after that
sequence the film screeches to a halt I
mean dead the issue is not the
production design or the costume design
or the music all of the technical
qualities of this film are top-notch a
plus material the problem is the
characters and the story the two most
important parts it's just not that
intriguing the film loses a sense of how
it's telling its story along the way and
unfortunately becomes dull I'm a big fan
of Ben Affleck even as an actor I like a
lot of the stuff that he does I was one
of the first people to say no he's gonna
be greatest Batman and guess what he was
and I love how he directs films but this
is his first film that has all the
pieces in place the pieces that you
would expect to make a great film but it
just doesn't really know what to do with
any of these pieces and for a long time
the film struggles to tell a compelling
story there's a great back story
involving a father and daughter played
by Chris Cooper and Ella Fanning there's
some really powerful stuff there that
does lend to some extreme moments of
tension and drama and there's a second
romance that blossoms in this film
between Ben Affleck and Zoe Saldana and
all the performers in this movie are
excellent everyone is really giving
their all it's just that for pretty much
the entirety of this film second act and
even into some of the third act the film
just doesn't do anything interesting it
took until the big final shootout for
there to be something to be excited
about by far the best part of this movie
is the technical qualities of it how
Affleck helm this movie and especially
the action sequences some of the set
pieces in this movie are brilliantly
filmed and there's a lot of great stunt
work and a good melding of CG with
practical but unlike his previous three
films the characters in this movie are
so vapid and the story itself rarely
ever breathes to life it was
disappointing this is not a terrible
movie as I said technically it's a
beautiful film there's a really great
score all the actors are giving their
all the story just deflated though I'm
going to give live by night a C+ this
was a more concise review and the reason
for that is because I have like five
more videos to do in the next week I
have a lot of Oscar films that I was
given early screeners for that I was
able to see and I'm going to be
reviewing a lot of those coming very
soon I hope you guys enjoy that and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you